ich habe letztens gesehen wie sich
irgend ein tollkühner teufelskerl einem
fahrrad mit viereckigen rädern gebaut
moment mal im schnitt des videos ist mir
aufgefallen dass es tatsächlich nur in
die photoshop des cliq bild dann elfer
ich konnte im gesamten internet kein
video finden von einem normalen fahrrad
mit viereckigen rädern im einsatz also
wer sich diese tollkühne teufelskerl
sein müssen und werde das ganze in
zukunft auch noch mal in die tat
umsetzen ab jetzt gerne und sagte wird
die glocke dann verpasst es nicht aber
jetzt zurück zum runden billard tisch
wie wäre es denn wenn man einen runden
billardtisch hat funktioniert das
überhaupt wie prallen die billardkugel
man genau ab und vielleicht macht es
sogar mehr spaß außerdem bin ich damit
wahrscheinlich der einzige der ihn
komplett perfekt kreisrunden willich hat
und das ist eigentlich ein grund genug
dieses video mit unterstützt von
cyberghost vpn mehr dazu später was
brauchen wir alles für den tisch als
erstes holzplatten und die habe ich
schon rum liegen außerdem brauchen wir
dieses grüne fließt das immer auf die
lettischen ist damit man dann auch drauf
spielen kann dürfen natürlich zwei köse
nicht wählen die man übrigens so
schreibt und kugeln kaufe ich auch so
begehrte konstruktion und damit einem pc
ich beginne als als neun im kreis und
dafür muss ich mir überlegen die große
sein soll also meter auf jeden fall ich
glaube ich habe mir dafür mal das grüne
bilder schließlich genau wissen wie groß
das ungefähr sich anfühlt und dafür muss
ich erstmal meine einkäufe auspacken pro
hd sind ja voll geil finden sich auch
gleich wo und wann das wichtigste das
schließt für den billardtisch sehr edel
das ist riesig ein meter ist es ganze
breit meter ist so viel das heißt dass
hier auch der radius von unserem bild
tisch sein moment mir ist klar dass
aufgefallen und zwar dachte ich okay ich
möchte lieber noch mal nach ob es auch
einen meter ist nicht dass ich etwas
macht und am ende ist es dann irgendwie
nur 199 cm oder so aber ich weiß nicht
mal wie glaubst du das ist ein meter es
ist 150 das heißt natürlich wir haben in
der die kreativität noch ein bisschen
mehr freiraum nach oben gut machen 118
solange sich mit holzplatten die kritik
manchmal messen
genau 26,5 mm dick dann kommt da das
vlies drauf das schneiden wir auch rund
um einen grundstoff drauf perfekt
kaschieren natürlich auch diese bande
diese heute 26 5 millimeter dann ist die
bande bei bill letztendlich auch immer
so abgeschrägt das machen wir natürlich
auch jetzt ist die frage reicht diese
platten dickel behauptet damit so eine
kugel davon gestoppt und ich haben
darüber geht ja alles reicht
[Musik]
damit das holz den kugeln aber besser
standhält mache ich anders als bei
herkömmlichen bilder zwischen keine
ganzjahr verkannte sondern eine leicht
stumpfe außerdem unterteile ich den rand
in sechs gleich große teile damit wir
nicht zuviel abfallholz haben bevor ich
jetzt hier weiter konstruiere habe ich
schon mal von den ersten teilen baupläne
herrschte ausgedruckt und shimano in der
werkstatt gegeben der die grundplatte
direkt in die tat umsetzt
während ich mich wieder ins büro
verkrieche und am 3d modell
weiterarbeiten
als erstes kommt eine schraube in die
mitte an die dann eine schnur befestigt
wird danach wird genau bei 59
zentimetern also dem radius in unser
billardtisch haben soll einen bleistift
am faden befestigt so lässt sich relativ
einfach einen kreis auf die große platte
zeichner den trick hab ich übrigens auch
schon für die bögen beim einem riesen
hamsterrad verwendet und schon kann
gesägt werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine wichtige frage die sich noch
unbedingt gestellt werden muss ist
natürlich wo die taschen also dass die
löcher in komplett ich habe gedacht da
das ja ein kreis ist mache ich die
einfach in die mittelrhein bzw macht
einfach einen mittelrhein sowie die
größte müssen ja dass man so eine kugel
aus das sind 52 millimeter also ich das
loch ungefähr 90 millimeter machen
eigentlich glaubt google das ist nämlich
das offizielle maß beim billard sind
nicht groß naja 85 kommen das ist schon
mal gut aus ich würde sagen so wird's
gemacht sondern kleines rohr hier dass
wir dieses überreste steckt außen ein
drucker
und auch mit 85 mm und zu guter letzt
drehen wir zu zweit den tisch um damit
das überschüssige holz am rand mit dem
wind nicht reserviert er ist gedacht
bündig gefräst werden kann
so kann man die erste kugel
rollt aktuell noch ein bisschen weil
dafür haben glaubt dass fred sind zu
hart
ich glaube alles was ich jemals über
will jetzt gelernt habe ist einfach mit
diesen tisch komplett hinüber also ich
würd die weiße kugel an machen mit wenig
halt neuen stiftung braucht
ich habe direkt verloren also das
wirklich die schnellste runde
über die jetzigen gekonnt
also das funktioniert
[Musik]
als es galt vor allem immer mehr ab als
man denkt genau wie die länder sperren
sämtliche streamingdienste abfallen wenn
man den vpn von cyber ausnutzt dem zwei
unseres heutigen video cyberghost vpn
bietet weltweit 8100 server aus 91
ländern zur auswahl womit ihr die ob
logging von 40 streaming-diensten wie
netflix und diesen platz ganz einfach
umgehen und filme und serien aus anderen
ländern schauen könnt
in deutschland könnte er sogar wieder
formel 1 kostenlos schauen auf der
website des österreichischen senders orf
der deutsche ohne vpn normal aussperrt
cyberghost vpn hat 38 millionen nutzer
15 of trust 24/7 deutschen support und
eine strikte blogs politik mit einem vpn
verschlüsselt zusätzlich an eure
online-aktivitäten damit ist in der
gesamte datenverkehr über eine andere
ip-adresse in einem land eurer wahl
läuft somit habt ihr volle und echte
privatsphäre
cyberghost vpn gibt es für alle geräte
und ihr könnt sie mit einem account
sogar mit bis zu sieben leuten teilen
ihr bekommt jetzt über den link in der
video beschreibung ganze 84 prozent
rabatt und zeigt nur 1 eur 94 im monat
und dank der 45 tage
geld-zurück-garantie ist das ganze auch
komplett risikofall
unser wunder billardtisch macht
mittlerweile vielleicht schon den
eindruck fertig zu sein ist aber noch
weit davon entfernt wirklich zu
funktionieren bevor man richtig darauf
spielen kann brauchen wir nämlich das
grüne fehlt damit die kugel nicht
ständig weg rollen und logisch ihre
tisch braucht beine mit denen er perfekt
waagrecht steht das erste waren
gestaltet sich hier passend in gebogenen
stil der tischplatte und kopiere es dann
noch zweimal um das virtuelle jetzt
realität werden zu lassen werden nun
wieder mit einer schnur zwei kreise
gezeichnet bevor die stichsäge gefragt
ist fürs grobe normal würde man jetzt
vielleicht eine super hübsche verbindung
anfertigen um die beine an der platte zu
befestigen aber ein paar versteckte
winkel verbinder machen den job auch
also das ist ungefährlich eingeölt oben
natürlich nicht denn da kommt jetzt glas
grüne tokio einmal drüber man muss sie
allerdings noch hier diesen ring genau
passgenau reinkriegen also das ein
bisschen anders ausfallen muss ich noch
so
geht er ist relativ leicht durch hält
sogar durch ist aber nicht schlimm denn
durch das fehlt mir das ganze nicht noch
ordentlich eingeklemmt
ist ja geil mit dem elektrischen tucker
sollte das jetzt eigentlich komplett
easy hinhauen der firma power
also wichtig ist auch wie man das ding
sehr sehr stark bezogen jetzt
[Musik]
ja wohl sehr fein so der kreis ich hoffe
dass jetzt nicht der put auch
[Musik]
naja diese ganze stoppte aber der ring
sitzt perfekt
[Musik]
sollten sie noch irgendwie diese run
stücke hier auch noch bezogen bekommen
und ich weiß nicht ob ich jedes ding
einzel beziehen will oder ob ich alles
auf einmal immerhin kriegt jetzt muss
ich als allererstes meine dinge wie das
genauso hin sortieren wie sie vorher
waren so und jetzt der masterplan ich
hoffe das ist ein masterplan und zwar
wird jetzt das hier so umgeschlagen
waren
[Musik]
so jetzt muss ein bisschen vorsichtig
sein
natürlich darf ja doch gar keinen fall
daran schneiden in echten stoff darunter
ist
da ist es nach außen gestülpt
hey ich glaub es funktioniert
tatsächlich
[Musik]
der wahrheit
über das hält sogar relativ gut aber
sieht es auch relativ gut aus und ich
finde sie ziemlich nass aus dass er noch
nicht mit stoff gearbeitet habe
[Musik]
hey hey der philosoph gekauft
bis hin zu geschwollen ich dachte ich
brauche den schwung mit sachen die
[Musik]
man da musst du fest
das heißt dass du die folgen hast du
nicht die halten
[Musik]
und um den boden vor den kugeln und
unsere ohren vor dem aufprall erneut ein
bisschen zu schonen haben wir dann noch
ein improvisiertes netz gebaut welches
absolut besser funktioniert als einrad
probiert es mal war es ja das nicht
darüber gehe und demselben server bundle
ein kick
die idee ist voll clever eigentlich weil
du kannst von überall her immer über das
noch anders rüber gehen
aber das schon gut dass am rand keine
löcher sind weil sonst weshalb wirklich
schon vorbei
solchen hier machen
[Musik]
aber es geht halt nichts gehört der
auffang sagt es wichtig noch
geht es auch richtig dumm
[Musik]
also man hat eine komplett andere
spielweise weil man die kugel immer
genau auf der anderen seite wo man es
erwartet einen entscheiden muss aber es
geht
ja
[Musik]
das ist nicht böse
ein
kleiner tipp wenn ihr mal einen bunten
miletic baut macht die banden ungefähr
meter hoch
es funktioniert wenn du es gemacht habe
oh
ja nein das wird der killer mut gewesen
ich habe zwei die richtig gut in der
mitte sind aber ich muss noch so
positioniert werden dass
diese
komplett
[Musik]
wenn wir noch eine regel eingeführt und
zwar dass es zwei weiße kugeln gibt und
zwar weil sonst immer bisschen blöd es
wird halt die kugel drin rand irgendwie
und wie es halt nie da wo man sie
braucht deswegen zwei sekunden kann man
sich immer ein bisschen ein aussuchen
ist geil man muss immer extrem sanft
drauf spielen weil sonst landet direkt
wollen
daraus danke nochmal an den heutigen
sponsor cyberghost vpn mit dem ihr eure
daten schützen und internationalen
content schauen könnte der in
deutschland blockiert ist für nur 1 euro
für 19 monate komplett risikofrei also
klickt auf den link in der beschreibung
ich bin damit raus macht's gut